[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it
is the bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international
pastor john ross hello friends this is
pastor john ross pastor doug is out this
evening
but how about an amazing fact gobies are
small fish
which during low tide like to swim in
rock pools on the edge of the ocean
one species the bathy gobis enjoys
jumping from one tidal pool to another
researchers intrigued by this habit
decided to investigate
they discovered that this little fellow
always jumps in the right direction
and adjusts the right distance without
ever landing on the rocks
although much of the area around the
pool is exposed rock
and the little fish cannot see from one
tidal pull to the next
it never misses how does this fish know
just how
far to leap and in what direction
scientists have discovered that when the
tide is in and covers the rocks
the little fish swims around and
memorizes all of the bumps and the
hollows
so that when the tide is out it knows
exactly where to jump
in other words this amazing fish is able
to pre-memorize
the shapes of all of the rocks and then
calculate where the water will pull
how would this small fish have enough
wisdom to go about in advance
and learn all of that well stay tuned
for more as amazing facts brings you
this edition
of bible answers live
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
hello friends welcome to bible answers
live and as the name says this is a live
international interactive bible study my
name is john ross pastor doug is out
this evening
but we are live and we are ready to take
your bible questions so if you have a
bible related question the phone line
here to the studio
is 800 463
again that's 800-463-7297
we're also live streaming this on our
facebook page you can go to the amazing
facts facebook page
and you'll be able to see the number
there and you'll be able to see us here
in the studio
and then joining us here in the studio
is pastor carlos munez who is going to
be working the phones
and helping me answer bible questions
pastor carlos is
one of our amazing facts speakers he's
our spanish evangelist
also the director of our training school
so we're just delighted that he's
joining us
and uh pastor carlos before we get to
the questions it's always a good idea to
start with prayer
definitely let's have a word of prayer
heavenly father we thank you for another
beautiful day of life and we thank you
for this opportunity to come together
and
spend time in your word with uh those
callers and those that are listening and
watching and so we just ask that your
spirit guide us
uh give us the discernment and the
knowledge so that we can have a deeper
understanding of your word and a closer
understanding of you
so we thank you father for this and we
ask this in jesus name amen
amen well pastor carlos we spoke at the
beginning of the program here just as we
uh just before we went on the air we
spoke about this little fish you
actually able to pull up a picture
of the bathy gobis which is very small i
mean it's probably what about an inch
maybe an inch
and um you know it swims around in these
tidal pools and he's able to jump from
one tidal pole to the other without
landing on the rocks and a little bit of
research that i was doing on this
this is not just a three inch jump some
of these fish can jump as much as
six feet from one tidal pool to another
so to get you know almost they have to
have a running start i'm sure
leap out of the water and yet they
always seem to get it just right in the
right direction
and of course scientists are intrigued
by this and they want to know how do
these fish do this
and as i mentioned in the fact they
actually have a way of pre-memorizing
all of the nooks and crannies
in the rocks when the water's there and
then the amazing thing is they're able
to calculate where the water will pull
and then with total confidence they jump
from one pool to the next and
you know how do these little things
that's brains are probably the size of
of of a pinhead able to figure this all
out well of course god
takes care of his creatures as the bible
says
and um not only does god provide the
skills and the abilities for these
creatures to thrive
but of course god is the source of all
wisdom and knowledge
and god wants us to be able to make wise
choices
our lives sometimes might seem as though
we're leaping in faith not quite sure
but god wants to give us wisdom
to help direct us so we know which way
we ought to go i was reminded of a bible
verse in james chapter 1 verse 5
it says if any of you lacks wisdom let
him ask of god who gives to all
liberally
and without reproach and it will be
given him
so then we have a problem that if we are
promised that if we're looking for
wisdom
god is the source of wisdom and he's
willing to give it to those who ask
amen yeah i was just thinking i i can
something i can't find my keys sometimes
some basic stuff it's interesting
because
you know that what that fish does is he
he prepares
before he has a time of preparation and
so i was just thinking spiritually
you know when when time of harvest when
we were blessed
to have the all the liberties and the
freedoms we have take advantage of it
because there's going to be a time of
of need of lacking to store up the word
in our minds just like that fish storing
up those rocks and
in its mind we got to store up the word
of god and that's
our safety friends we have a book we'd
like to make available to anyone who is
listening or if you're viewing this
on um our facebook channel it's entitled
knowing god's will and uh the book is
incar entitled actually life in the
spirit is what the book's called
and we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls and asks now
if you're in north america you want to
call and we'll send you the book if
you're outside of north america you can
go to the amazing facts website and
you'll be able to read the book for free
we have a library and you can actually
type in there life in the spirit you can
read the book
but call and we'll send it to you if
you're in north america the number is
800-835-6747 that is our resource
phone line and if you call just ask for
the free offer it's life in the spirit
and we'll be happy to send that out to
anyone who calls and asks
all right pastor carlos i think we are
ready for our first call of this evening
all right this is first one
yep we've got chris in florida chris
welcome to the program
yes pastors hello hi we can hear you
yes thank you very much for taking my
call
thank you question uh to help me
understand the verb from first
corinthians
first corinthians 8 9. all right let me
read that for those who might be driving
in a car
it says i am driving too soon oh okay
all right yeah let me read it for you it
says but be aware list
somehow this liberty of yours becomes a
stumbling block to those who are weak
yes so what freedom is he talking about
freedom in christ yes let me explain a
little bit the situation that you find
happening here
of course paulie's writing to believe is
in corinth there were both
uh gentile believers and also jewish
believers that made up the church
mostly gentiles though in the city of
corinth there were still some of the
jewish believers that
um well were rather concerned and some
gentile believers as well
who were concerned about eating food
from the marketplace
that had been offered to an idol and so
there was a little bit of a dispute
amongst the believers
some saying you shouldn't eat it so i'm
saying you should eat it
paul says you know if it's good food and
it's sanctioned by the word of god in
other words it's clean food you can eat
it
um you know if it's offered to an idol
or not don't ask it
you can eat it you're okay that's you
know we we know that these idols are
nothing
but he says if it's going to make a
brother stumble
who might be weak in the faith he won't
do that
and so that's really the issue that's
been addressed there had to do with
uh those new believers who perhaps were
weak in the faith and i think the
principle for that
pastor carlos even today is that in our
christian experience
you know let's be sensitive to new
believers who might have just come to an
understanding of christ
who might be growing in their faith and
the last thing we want to do is say
something or do something that's going
to weaken their commitment to christ
and that's good counsel that paul is
giving us does that help chris
yes but is he talking about freedom only
in
eating or in general well primarily it
had to do here with eating because that
was an issue that was
being discussed if you read up a little
bit further on it actually talks about
the food that was offered to the
to the idle in the marketplace yeah yeah
so that's okay
thank you very much all right you're
welcome thanks for your for your call
you're gonna say paul
mentions something very similar that
came to mind in galatians chapter five
he says for brethren you have been
called unto liberty
only use not liberty for an occasion to
the flesh but by love
serve one another ah so a similar thing
was happening in galatia and paul road
later there were
there was this similar issue that was
occurring all right who do we have next
next we have uh charles from newport
richie
florida hello charles hey
how's it going we're blessed how are you
doing what's your question for tonight
my question for tonight is this um
i know it's wrong to spend money on the
sabbath
but what if you're spending money for
like medicines for your health
like coffee sure yeah it's a good
question
good question now the principle there is
you know
even jesus explained that it's good to
do good on the sabbath so if you can
help
um someone who's suffering on the
sabbath and if that means
going to the pharmacy and buying some
medicine to relieve pain
or suffering on the sabbath that is in
harmony with
the sabbath principle that's different
than you know shopping for a new car on
the sabbath or doing your regular
monthly
grocery shopping we want to do that a
different time but this is sort of an
emergency situation
it's for the purpose of relieving
suffering and pain and yes it is
appropriate if
it you know it'll help to get some
medicine especially if it's
life-threatening the last thing you want
to do is
you know say well we don't want to go
help this person
um you know i think that's true even in
other circumstances on the sabbath if if
somebody is
in physical need you need doctors to
still help
uh to help take care of emergency
emergency those things are
are appropriate uh with with the sabbath
truth
um does that help charles it actually
does the reason i was asking that
question because
i am i'm just now getting over covered
you know me and my family work we've
been
working free but i had to spend money on
the sabbath to try to get the medicines
that i needed for
like shingles and the uh uh my uh
my pocket and everything so that's the
reason i'm asking
yeah perfectly appropriate to provide
medicine on the sabbath to to relieve
suffering
that's that's in harmony with the spirit
of the sabbath thanks for your call
charles
appreciate that uh who do we have next
we have next we have a navel
from new york hello neville you're on
the air
hi pastor john and pastor carlos how you
guys doing
doing well bless thank you hey thanks
for having me
i just have a question so um i was
reading
romans chapter 10 and verse 11.
um and i can read it here very quickly
it says for the scripture states
whosoever believeth on him shall not be
ashamed
so i was wondering about what the word
is saying mean so i
wanted to look up the scripture that
paul was referencing
and my bible points me to isaiah 28
and verse 16. so in isaiah it says
therefore thus faith the lord god behold
i lay in zion
for a foundation a stone a tribestone
a precious cornerstone a sir foundation
be that believer shall not make faith
so in isaiah the word is this views but
in romans 10 11 the word of shame is
used
so i'm trying to understand what does it
mean exactly when it says the same
in romans 10 11 because the crosstalk is
first
um it didn't help my understanding sure
absolutely good good question now often
you'll find in the new testament when
the apostle is quoting from the old
testament he will sometimes
quote obviously the old testament
written in hebrew the new testament is
written in greek
they would often quote from the
septuagint which was the greek version
of the hebrew old testament
they didn't always quote exact word for
word but they would get the key
idea that they wanted to emphasize of
course paul was writing under the
inspiration of the holy spirit
and if you look at the context of isaiah
28 16
the cornerstone there is referring to
his christ
and here paul this is one of my favorite
verses by the way
romans chapter 10 verse 11 whoever
believes in him will not be put to
shamed or
that's the new king james all will not
be ashamed
he's encouraging believers to put their
faith in jesus
he is the cornerstone that was rejected
by the master builders but in reality it
was the foundation that held up the
whole
the whole temple the whole house and um
he's emphasizing the fact that
the believer puts their faith in christ
the promises they won't be ashamed
okay yeah that actually makes it more
clear for me thanks for answering my
questions yeah great question thanks for
asking
all right who do we have next next we
have e frank
from astoria new york hello eve frank
hi frank you're on the air yes hello are
you there waiting to hear you
hear you what's your question yes uh
good after
good evening pastor ross and good
evening pastor
uh carlos uh my question for you two
gentlemen tonight is the following i
i just want to ask you is it stated in
any
scripture in the entire holy bible
that it is sinful to believe
in the creations of the universe i was
told at one time
in a science club that i should not be
believing in what i believe the voyager
2 exploratory probe
and other type of space exploration
vehicles is it sinful to believe in that
no i don't think so
uh matter of fact we have a verse in
psalms 19 verse 1 it says the heavens
declare
the glory of god so and then it goes on
to say the firmament shows he's handy
for all his handiwork so
when one gazes up into the sky and the
more we learn about
um you know the planets and the stars
and the suns and how
big the universe is and you know our
little milky way galaxy is just one of
billions and trillions of galaxies we
can't even begin to count
we begin to get a picture of how big god
is
and how that all of these different
systems move around
in uh different orbits and patterns and
it's really a revelation of god's power
and his creative
ability and so yes the bible actually
says the heavens declare the glory of
god
yeah it's actually i i came to under to
know that god exists was through science
through ecosystems the order order
purpose everything had a reason to be
yeah and so that's actually showed me
that if all of this is an order then
why is somebody teaching us yeah that
this is not right this is just random
yeah it didn't make sense
yeah does that help you frank yes
all right great thanks for your question
good question i just wanted to give him
one
voice if he's still listening romans
chapter 1 verse 20 talks about
why did you read did you have it there
yeah i have it here for the invisible
things of him
uh from the creation of the world are
clearly seen being understood by the
things that are made even his eternal
power and godhead
so that they are without excuses that's
right so so by seeing at the things that
are made we get an idea of the one who
made it it reveals to us about about the
king
who made all things all right great
question who do we have next amen we
have next we have guy
from new plymouth good evening guy
yes thank you thanks for
calling yeah we can we can hear you get
real close to your phone
and your question tonight
uh why is the gate on the holy city open
after the holy okay
good question uh first of all when the
new jerusalem comes down at the end of
the 1000 years the end of the millennium
uh it's at that point that jesus sets
his feet on the mount of olives in
zechariah
and it opens up and forms a great valley
the new jerusalem comes to rest all the
redeemed
are in the new jerusalem they come down
with the new jerusalem
and with god the wicked are then
resurrected and they're outside the new
jerusalem and i believe at that point
the gates will actually be closed
because you've got the good on the
inside you've got the bad on the outside
you have the final great white throne
judgment that you can read about in
revelation chapter 20
at the end of that every knee bows every
tongue confesses that jesus christ is
lord even the devil himself acknowledges
that god is just god is fair now that's
not
a repentance by any means on the part of
the devil of the wicked it's just an
acknowledgement of the facts
because no sooner do they say that when
they're actually the devil is able to go
out and deceive
the bible refers to them as morgan and
gog and magog
numbered as the sand of the seas and
they actually
mount an attack upon the new jerusalem
then it is that fire comes down
and devours them so that's the final
destruction of the wicked
then in chapter 21 revelation 21 you
read about the new heavens and the new
earth
wherein dwells righteousness so when god
creates the earth
anew there's no need for the gates of
the new
jerusalem to be closed but the redeemed
will come in and out
a matter of fact it tells us i believe
in isaiah that from one month to another
from one sabbath to another all will
come
and worship before god they'll journey
up to jerusalem
so all right well thanks for that call
who do we have next
next we have glenn from bethel ohio good
evening glenn welcome
yes thank you very much for taking my
call appreciate it
you know there's a scripture that uh
that i had concerns a knife is very
important at any time
and particularly i believe it's
important our national
cri is in crisis at the time and that is
second chronicles 7 14.
and i just wanted some clarification on
some language right there because
i don't believe that the people really
know knowing by his name his name is not
lord
his name is not god his name is yahweh
and he says if my people that must be
him
speaking who are called by my name
will turn from their wicked ways and
seek my face if they
if my people who are called by my name
will do that
then he says i will hear from heaven
god will within heaven and will he will
forgive their sins and heal their land i
just wanted to hear some clarification
on
who's talking and and of the language
sure
absolutely you know i think you're dead
on when you when you're talking about
who's speaking in verse 14 if my people
who are called by my name humble
themselves it's really talking about the
believers
in this case in in its broader
historical sense it's referring to
israel
of course the new testament era god does
not have a specific nation
that he refers to as my people but all
of those who believe in christ they
become
spiritual jews and they the promises the
the inheritance of the promise made to
abraham
god is calling upon his people to humble
themselves
to seek for his blessing to seek for
guidance
and the promise is he will forgive and
he will heal them so
if ever there was a time for believers
for christians to
take a hold of this verse i think now is
the time amen
and also in the context it's he's
talking to solomon yes and god is
telling solomon you know
it might happen in the future that they
disobey they rebel from me
and this is the way to come back to me
right so we have some examples where
that did happen where
the jews rebelled and we have those in
jerusalem in particular the babylonian
captivity
and there were those like daniel and
others who humbled himself who prayed
and we have that prayer of daniel
recorded in daniel
and eventually deliverance came they
were able to return back to their land
so
see a fulfillment in that verse all
right i think we have time for a few
more before i break
uh pastor carlos who do we have next we
have here
uh denise from muskogee oklahoma good
evening denise welcome
hey good evening thank you so much for
taking my call my question was
based on exodus chapter 12 verse 24 and
25 where it talks about the passover
and it says how the ordinances of the
passover should be done forever
and that we should keep that service why
don't we do that today
okay very good because the bible tells
us that christ is our passover
uh we don't sacrifice lambs anymore
because they all pointed to jesus the
lamb of god who takes away the sins of
the world
so as long as israel was looking for the
coming of the messiah that was to be a
perpetual sign
a reminder continual looking forward to
the coming of the messiah
when jesus came paul talks about the old
covenant that is coming to an end and a
new covenant that was coming in
when jesus died on the cross he brought
an end to sacrifices
yeah and uh praise god for that
otherwise we'd still be
sacrificing lambs but really they just
pointed forward to jesus
jesus is the fulfillment and paul says
christ is our passover
so there's still a lot of good lessons
we can learn because they all point to
jesus
but there's no need to sacrifice the
lamb any longer
thank you thank you so much appreciate
it all right thank you calling
all right we have uh what do we have
next we have
pamela from california first time caller
pamela
pamela first time caller welcome pamela
hi hi hi pastor doug and i'm ross
and carlos yes thanks for calling and
your
question tonight my question is i am a
christian
but i haven't been baptized and i tried
to go to church to get baptized you know
especially one on a
side of this um worshipped on saturday
but they're all closed right now due to
the virus
okay so do i need to be baptized
uh by water or did i get baptized by the
holy spirit
that is a great question i'm so glad you
asked you know
um both are needed we need to be
baptized by the spirit we need to be
baptized by water jesus said in john
chapter 3
except the man be born of water and of
the spirit he cannot see the kingdom or
enter the kingdom of god
so there's two parts to making that
profession of faith
one is we ask for the forgiveness of our
sins we get on our knees we pray
god forgives us we ask for the holy
spirit but after we receive
the grace and the gift of god we want to
make a public declaration that we're on
god's side and the way we do that is
through baptism it's a public
declaration saying i'm choosing to
follow
jesus and there is a wonderful blessing
involved in baptism i do understand you
know
in our church we've had to try and work
around some of these we've had some
folks who wanted to be baptized we had
to kind of postpone the baptism for a
few weeks to try and
have things settle down but i would
encourage you
don't give up on the idea of getting
baptized reach out to a good bible
believing
church or pastor and tell him that
you're interested in getting baptized
and i'm sure
something could be worked out but you
know when jesus was baptized and he came
up out of the water and you can read
this in
in the gospels um there was a voice from
heaven
actually god spoke himself and he said
this is my beloved son in whom i'm well
pleased
and uh even though we might not hear god
say
that when we're baptized we know that
god is pleased because we're making a
stand to follow him and it's just a
beautiful experience so
pamela i want to encourage you to uh
keep pursuing that and don't give up you
know if you call one church and they
close and they say well you know we're
not going to be open for a little while
try and connect with the past and and
share with him
does that help does it yes does it
matter um what church i go to as long as
i get baptized
well i think you want to find a bible
believing church so one of the questions
yeah
yeah i would always ask and say you know
what do you guys believe because even
on the subject of baptism there are
differing opinions some people say well
you only have to be baptized
with sprinkling others say you get
baptized with i've even heard of people
that are
baptizing with salt and rose petals but
no that's not what the bible says
the bible talks about it i have to be
dunked yes
yes yes because of the symbolism that's
connected with that it's
it's death to the old resurrection to
the new and
and also the word baptism means to be
completely submerged or to be completely
covered by
so to be baptized in water means you're
completely covered in water or
completely submerged as jesus was
in mark it says he came out of the water
and the holy spirit came upon him in a
mighty way so
yes you want to you want to be baptized
right you know i would encourage you
um family if you haven't done this yet
amazing facts has a set of
lessons bible lessons one of the topics
is baptism
and it goes through all the bible verses
on that i would encourage you
it's all free if you would call our
resource number and just ask say i'd
like to enroll in the free amazing facts
bible school they will send you the
lessons and you can read it on your own
time and
it'll answer a lot of your questions so
i encourage you to do that not only your
panel but anyone who is listening
to do that just call our resource phone
line the number is 800-835-6747
i'm going to say that again pamela you
might want to write it down
800 six 835
four seven that is our resource phone
line and anyone you can enroll for free
right now in the amazing facts study
guide series
it's got a lot of great information and
pamela one more thing when you call that
number
you can ask for a book and we'll send it
to you for free it's called baptism
is it really necessary baptism
is it really necessary so just ask for
that when you call
say you'd like to enroll in the bible
school but also ask for the book called
baptism
is it really necessary and thank you for
your call well you know pastor carlos
we're coming up on our break and friends
we see you waiting don't go away we're
not done yet we're just taking a quick
break and
we'll be back with more bible questions
and if you have a bible question the
number to call
here to the studio is 800 800-835-6747
that's 800-835-6747 if you don't get
through right away just stay on the line
our
call screeners will get to you any
bible-related question
that's our goal to see what does the
bible say and we have some resources in
front of us we'll be giving you
additional materials
that'll help you in your study of god's
word so again don't go away
just uh give us a call and we look
forward to more bible questions
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
in six days god created the heavens and
the earth
for thousands of years man has
worshipped god on the seventh day of the
week
now each week millions of people worship
on the first day
what happened why did god create a day
of rest
does it really matter what day we
worship who is behind this great shift
discover the truth behind god's law and
how it was changed
visit sabbathtruth.com
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
did you know that noah was present at
the birth of abraham
okay maybe he wasn't in the room but he
was alive and probably telling stories
about his floating zoo
from the creation of the world to the
last day events of revelation
biblehistory.com is a free resource
where you can explore
major bible events and characters
enhance your knowledge of the bible
and draw closer to god's word go deeper
visit biblehistory.com
what if you could know the future
what would you do
what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past
alexander the great becomes king when
he's only 18 but he's a
military prodigy 150 years in advance
cyrus had been named rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
the gospel writers see his death as
a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by pastor
doug batchelor
explores the most striking bible
prophecies that have been dramatically
fulfilled throughout history
kingdoms in time get your copy today
available now on dvd blu-ray or usb
for more information visit kingdoms in
time.com
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god
and his plan to save you so what are you
waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life
today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's
our 800-463-7297 for more bible answers
live
hello friends welcome back this is bible
answers live as
you heard on our intro leading into the
second half
of our program if you have a bible
related question
the we'd love to hear from you the
number to call is 800-463-7297
and we are live streaming at the amazing
facts uh facebook page so you're welcome
to join us there as well and you'll also
see the number
on our facebook page uh pastor doug is
out this evening but
uh working the phones with me pastor
carlos doing a good job
learning the ropes keeping up yeah so
we're glad that he's helping us
um we're gonna go to our very next
caller and let's just keep moving along
we got a number of folks waiting let's
go we have rick from ontario canada
first time caller welcome rick what's
your question
yes uh good evening hello
yeah and your question this evening rick
yes uh just uh it's a
regard oh rick you there
you're there yeah yeah you cut it for a
second um yes
sorry that that no problem yeah so it's
regarding the sabbath uh
i own a construction company and we do
come across
the odd time uh just recently uh within
the last six months i've been watching
your programs
amazing facts and uh we've adapted and
have adhered with to the sabbath
a lot of my family a lot of my family
has we're no longer working
on these saturdays right so now
but the discrepancy is is that i do have
some staff
that choose to work on the sabbath
and i have some sub trades that i don't
have control over
on whether or not they come in and work
on construction projects and stuff and
i'm wondering how that relates to
myself with it being my company okay
good question rick and first of all let
me just say praise the lord we're we
like to hear testimonies of folks who
uh have looked at the ten commandments
and say wait a minute there's a blessing
here in keeping the sabbath and
and you will be blessed uh stay faithful
in that
with reference to owning a business the
bible principle that we find is
those within your gates so those that
you actually have
authority over so um
if you have a business and you have
employees working on sabbath
and you closed the business on sabbath
you know then
the employees wouldn't be working
subcontractors
that's a little bit different because
you probably don't have as much control
over them
in dictating their schedule depending
upon what the project is sometimes
the owners will have more saying that so
you know in those type of situations
pray for wisdom ask god to guide you
allow the spirit to kind of convict you
and
lead you in the way that you want to go
there's not always a clear
answer but you want to do the best you
can
in keeping the sabbath for those that
are within your
gates so those who are under your
jurisdiction your employees
those type of things okay now in in the
event that an employee
of mine doesn't have the same beliefs as
me and was wishing to work
overtime or to come in to make extra
money what do i do in that case
you know i i think is the owner of the
company if if
they're asking you if they can come in
i guess you could say you know i would
prefer that you work on
sunday and not on saturday saturday is
nice i have been doing
that's a good answer that's a good
answer that's what i have been doing
okay great thank you
thank you very very both for all your
time and your efforts it's great program
you guys are doing a great job
thank you rick and uh praise god all the
best for you and your family
uh next quarter that we have encouraging
right yeah next caller is brett
from chattanooga tennessee good evening
brett
hello pastors thank you for having me
thanks for taking my call you're welcome
your question tonight so my question is
from
colossians chapter 1 verses 9 and 10
and basically i'm i'm seeking wisdom
of understanding what it means like are
jesus and his angels praying for us
okay well here we have the apostle paul
let me just read carlos do you have it
right there in front of you why don't
you read it for us
verse 9 and 10. it says for this cause
we also since the day we heard of it
do not cease to pray for you and to
desire that you might be filled with the
knowledge of his will
in all wisdom and spiritual
understanding verse 10 that you might
walk
walk worthy of the lord unto all
pleasings being fruitful in every good
work
and increasing in the knowledge of god
so your your question there is
um are you asking about believers
praying for other believers
are jesus and the angels praying for us
yeah our yeah
jesus and his angels praying for us well
you know
jesus is interceding for us and uh
that's why we pray in jesus name but we
need to initiate that prayer i mean
there's still many blessings that god is
good
and god has blessed us even unbelievers
god is patient
and he pulls out blessings on the good
and the bad
and god is constantly trying to draw
people to himself but there is a point
where we need to decide to seek after
christ
we need to come in prayer we need to
pray in jesus name
so there's god reaching out to us but
not everyone that
he's reaching to will respond god is
wanting us to respond and what paul is
here
paul is saying i'm praying for you that
you might be blessed and strengthened in
your walk and
so it's it's very clear that there's
value in praying for
each other and telling each other hey
i'm praying for you brother i'm praying
for you
you know what can i pray for and there's
there's power in there and of course
always praying in jesus name
and christ intercedes on our behalf
awesome thank you guys all right great
question thank you brad
you have a little book it's called teach
us to pray written by pastor doug
and um we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls and asks it's talking
about
how do we pray the number is
800-835-6747 that is our resource phone
line and you can ask for the book it's
called
teach us to pray all right who do we
have next next we have emmanuel from
ghana in africa hey emmanuel can you
hear us
emmanuel in africa going once going
twice all right we might have to come
back we might have
lost the the line there give us another
quality manual and we'll we'll try to
get you in just a bit
uh rick in new jersey yes um
how are you today doing well thanks for
calling
um i want to refer to acts 16
verse 17 where paul and barnabas are
going to the different cities preaching
the gospel
and the fortune teller or the woman was
following them for days saying
uh these matters preach in the way of
salvation
and paul after a while became annoyed
and uh called on on god to
drive out the evil spirits from within
her which
did happen when she was cleansed um
of course the the men who were enjoying
her uh
lost lost money because they were using
her
you know for profit right but my
question is
um you would think that an evil spirit
would say something different than
make way for the lord these men are
speaking salvation
i know that annoyed paul in part of this
because
she probably wasn't sincere she was a
rational
but why would an evil spirit say
something like that
you know that sort of say something like
that that's a great question you know we
have examples
where an evil spirit confronted christ
and the evil confessed
that jesus is the christ the son of god
and jesus
would at times tell those evil spirits
to be quiet and then he'd cast them out
so it's as if the evil spirit in the
presence of god
uh in the presence of um the witness the
gospel
almost needs to acknowledge it now of
course the reason why she was saying
that she was moved upon by the evil
spirit
the evil spirit was trying to complicate
the work that paul and barnes were
trying to do
which was to stir up controversy and
of course things did break out and um it
got even worse
but it's strange how that here even an
evil spirit has to confess the truth
i don't know whether just in the
presence of power and the spirit
convicting but
we do we do see that even in the case of
of the evil spirits with jesus
i don't know carlos do you ever but also
it's interesting that it also set up the
uh
what happened from there from then they
were put into prison
and of course that's when an angel of
the lord came during the night while
they were singing and
and the chains fell off and and they
were released from prison from that so
it's sort of
set up for that chain of events to
happen which is kind of neat
yes i mean there's a so many things
happening in these missionary journeys
of paul
that's just incredible a whole book of
acts but it is interesting that yeah
even
evil spirits will acknowledge god and
the good news with that is you know
jesus said
to his believers to the disciples that
he would give power
to cast out evil spirits meaning that
the evil spirit would acknowledge
who jesus is and in the name of christ
there was power and there was
deliverance
pastor carlos you've probably
experienced this too i know i have
growing up in africa and doing quite a
bit of work in africa
we've confronted some folks who were
demon possessed i mean
fully demon possessed the way you you
read about in the bible that kind of
demon possession and
in times like that boy i tell you you
cry out and
claim the promise and claim the name of
christ and miracles
occur i just powerful lies are changed
so
there is power in the word of god you
see the struggle also with a person
actually wanting to be liberated and
yes the devil doesn't want to let them
go it's a it's a real battle it's an
amazing experience as paul says we don't
fight against flesh and blood but
against principalities and powers amen
thanks for call rick who do we have next
next we have brandon from lincoln
nebraska another first time caller
hello brandon hi thank you pastors
um i'll try to be quick with my question
um i do believe in the sabbath and i've
had
a real hard time turning my life over to
christ um
i had a real hard time with alcoholism
and drug abuse and i didn't know if
there's any
any bible verse maybe could help or
absolutely i'm so glad you asked you
know your
your experience brandon isn't unique uh
every person who is convicted
by the spirit and wants to live a holy
life is going to face a battle
just like we said the devil doesn't like
like the lady's captives go
go easily don't get discouraged um
you know claim the promises of the bible
the bible says if the son sets you free
you
shall be free indeed you go to jesus and
say lord i need your help and then
you know don't don't get discouraged if
you stumble and fall don't give up
go right back and say lord i need more
of you i need to trust in you i need to
hold on to you
and what i always encourage people to do
is
do what you can meaning
set a time every day to read the bible
and to pray that's something you can do
the bible speaks of abiding in christ
jesus said you cannot bear fruit of
yourself but you can't abide in him or
abide in me
so we can abide in christ through prayer
through the study of his word and then
the spirit of god
is able to work in us to make those
changes that are needed
to bring us into harmony with god's will
how do you abide in christ
every day set some time you don't have
to read
you know for an hour start with just
one chapter and spend some time in
prayer and just do that faithfully no
matter whether you stumble or fall along
the way
keep asking keep seeking and the promise
is
god is able to deliver us amen one thing
that helped me brandon
is uh take bible verses bible promises
and post them on the wall and every time
you have a battle or a struggle come
look at that promise pray it
last pastor uh doug preach this yeah
sabbath
reclaim the promise right claim the
problem one of my favorites is isaiah 41
10 do not fear for i am with you be not
dismayed for i am your god i will
strengthen you
i will always help you i will uphold you
with my righteous right hand
put those verses on the wall and and and
when the moment comes
hold on to those promises all right
brandon hey can we have a word of prayer
for you right now
absolutely yeah let's do that dear
father in heaven we just want to lift
our brand in a very special way you know
his heart he wants to do what's right he
wants to serve you and follow you
but lord we do know that we have an
adversary and he's going to do
everything he can to
keep us chained and in bondage to this
sinful world and
sinful ways but lord we know victory is
in jesus and so we just want to pray for
brandon that you would give him victory
and strength and
i just set him free lord that he could
truly be everything that you wanted to
be
and we pray this not only for him but
for all of those who are listening we
pray this for ourselves lord that we can
be
truly um completely dedicated to you
and to your service for we ask this in
jesus name amen
god bless brandon you know i have a book
we want to send you
um if you can remember to call the
number it's 800-835-6747
the book is called the positive no
oh here it is the power i have to
remember what it is the power of a
positive no
tips for resisting temptation the power
of a positive no i think you'll really
enjoy that
so call and ask for the book tips for
resisting temptation and the power of a
positive no
and i think you'll be encouraged who do
we have next next we have christina from
sandy oregon
first time caller welcome christina
hi thank you thanks for calling and your
question
yes i just have a question about
how can i be truly happy in heaven
if my kids aren't there well you know
that's going to be
um that's going to be a challenge i
think all of us want to have our
children and our loved ones and our
parents and family our spouse
we want them in the kingdom with us and
probably
even more than we want our loved ones in
the kingdom jesus wants
uh our loved ones in the kingdom but god
also acknowledges freedom of choice
so we do the best we can to be a witness
and an encouragement
and ultimately you know our loved ones
our children are going to have to make
decisions
don't get discouraged if you don't see
your children making decisions for
christ
keep praying for them and let the spirit
work i have experiences i know people
who
you know he wasn't a believer and he
wasn't interested in religion but his
mother faithfully prayed
even after she had passed away he
finally came to the lord
and you know one day in the kingdom
she'll be surprised to see your son
so god does answer prayer um the best we
can be is be an example
but you know also recognize that heaven
is going to be a happy place yeah there
might be
a few tears that have to be wiped away
revelation says that god will wipe away
every tear from every eye there will be
no more pain no more sorrow
the former things won't come to mind so
those painful memories will
be removed but put it in the lord's
hands
trust in him just give your children to
him and allow god to work things out
okay thank you all right thank you amen
next we have dante from uh here in
california good evening dante what's
your question for us today
uh uh good evening blessings brothers uh
hey wait
can you hear me yes we can on the air
okay sorry
and it's actually dante but hey all
right well i i had a question
it's fine uh i had a question regarding
the apocrypha
i've heard pastor doug batchelor mention
it many times and with all due respect
kind of sounds like with contempt in a
sense
and i just wanted to ask about the
origins because i've heard that it
does originate from kind of has like a
very shady or seedy
place of origin so i wanted to learn
more and see why
yeah the apocryphal books um you won't
find it in your typical protestant bible
uh some of the catholic versions would
would have a cluster of books
in in the middle between the old
testament the new testament and they
called the apocryphal
the reason they not part of the
protestant bible are not part of the
canon
is because the authorship of those books
was somewhat dubious to begin with and
then some of
the the ideas presented contradicted
established teachings in the old
testament so they weren't included in
there
now there's some good history in the
apocryphals you can read about the
maccabees and others and you know it's a
historical source
but when it comes to putting them on par
with the inspired portion of the rest of
the bible which is inspired
all scriptures given by the inspiration
of god according to timothy
um you know we don't want to do that so
they they don't really meet the grade
for the bible now let me explain what i
mean by that
the dead sea scrolls have proven beyond
a shadow of a doubt
the old testament so there's no real
doubt as to what the old testament is
we know the books of the old testament
the ones that we have in our bible today
are the same as the books that were read
in the time of jesus
when it comes to the new testament the
ones who
are found in the new testament at least
the authors of the new testament
the condition was you needed to be an
eyewitness of christ
so you'll find all of the new testament
books and i'll get to paul in just a
minute but all of the other
new testament books are actually written
by those who are eyewitnesses of jesus
or
were in contact with jesus around that
same time
or firsthand they heard from the
disciples directly
paul is somewhat unique in that yes he
was a contemporary he was
alive at the time of christ we don't
know if he actually met jesus in person
but he was especially
called by god on the road to emmaus and
then testified by
other believers and leaders within the
christian church
so if you weren't an eyewitness of
christ or the apostles if you weren't
paul
your letter or your book probably didn't
make it in the new testament
and that was the criteria that they used
in putting together the new testament
does that help dante all right yeah that
actually does
thank you all right great thanks for
calling you know we do have a little
book
if you'd like to learn more about the
bible it's called the ultimate resource
and it's all about the bible talks about
the origins and different translations
and we'll be happy to send it to anyone
who calls and asks the number is
800-835-6747
that's 800-835-6747 and you can ask for
the book it's called the ultimate
resource
if you're outside of north america you
can still read it just go to the amazing
facts
website just amazingfacts.org and you'll
be able to read it there on our free
library
okay who do we have next next we have uh
richard from california
good evening richard your question for
tonight
uh good evening pastors thank you for
taking my call
yes my reference bible is in genesis 3
my question verses 22 to 24.
god makes a statement after driving out
adam and eve
from the garden after they have fallen
or disobeyed him
the statement that he makes he places a
mighty tariff
unless they take home the tree of life
and a
flaming sword i'm assuming to guard it
the question i have did god make that
statement right there and there when he
drove them out
and if so was it just intended for adam
and eve
or somebody else oh good question all
right so after adam and eve took of the
forbidden fruit it was never god's will
that they have a knowledge of evil
god wanted them to have a knowledge of
good but when they succumbed to the
devil's temptation
they added the fruit they had a
knowledge of evil and all of the
terrible consequences that came with
that
the life-giving properties that
perpetuated
the life that god had given to adam and
eve was found in the tree of life
had they eaten from the tree of life if
you read the verses it seems as though
they would have lived
they would have continued living so god
uh separated them from the tree of life
and that's where the angel was guarding
the way to the tree of life
the tree of life was in the garden of
eden so in essence adam and eve were
driven from the garden of eden
an angel was stationed at the gate with
this flaming sword
it was not only to keep adam and eve out
of the garden it was to keep any of
their
descendants out of the garden of eden
now we believe the garden of eden
eden was probably on the earth and we
don't know how long but
during the time of uh you have cain and
abel and seth and their descendants
the garden of eden was probably still
there so they could walk up to the gate
maybe look inside but that's as far as
they could get but before the flood
we believe the garden of eden was
removed and taken to heaven
how do we know that well the bible
speaks of the tree of life in heaven now
and of course there was nothing wrong
with the garden of eden adam and eve
were sent outside of the garden and
i think when the redeemed get to heaven
they will actually get to enter into
that garden of eden
again and adam and eve will will get to
enter in there as well
so it was kind of a memorial for them to
remember where they used
where they came from and how they fell
away up to that time of noah so
and probably for their children they
could say tell us the story of what's
happening there that's right
yeah all right all right thank you
richard good good question
all right next we have matthios from
georgia good evening mathias what's your
question for us
um hi my question is what should i tell
someone
who has been baptized incorrectly but
strongly believes they
have been saved from baptism alone
okay well you know i would again direct
them to the words of jesus except the
man be born of
water and of the spirit encounter into
the kingdom of heaven and then we need
to allow the bible to interpret itself
if we're going to be baptized we want to
be baptized according to the method that
the bible gives which is baptism by
immersion
now there's a lot of different views of
baptism and i think that's where if
somebody's sincere wanting to do the
will of god
and they're willing to sit down and
study it's not very difficult to show
them from the bible what baptism is
we have examples of jesus being baptized
he went down into the water and then he
came up out of the water john the
baptist was baptizing as well
and in the new testament we have many
examples of people being baptized by
immersion now if someone refuses to
study
um you know you can pray for them you
can be a witness you you can't force
them
uh if they're open and they're willing
to ask questions you can direct them to
resources
but um you'd be the best example that
you can be
all right thank you all right thanks for
your call
all right next we have henry from the
bronx new york
good evening henry what's your question
first this is your stomping grounds
carlos yes yeah close
yeah henry in your question tonight my
question is
is there any type of is there anything
christ here now
or or or when will he be released
because
i was told by this uh i'm gonna mention
the name of the jewish
walt dogs rabbi he's leading jesus
christ he said the antichrist is here
already
okay well you know um i would have to
agree with him on that i mean i i don't
know if i agree with him as to who the
antichrist is but
i do believe the antichrist is here now
the word antichrist
sometimes throws people off the actual
word antichrist means
in the place of christ it's not
necessarily opposed to christ but it
could be someone
claiming the positions or the
authorities that only belong to christ
and some of those would be
the power to forgive sins claiming
worship from others
uh being able to dictate the conscience
of man meaning telling people how they
ought to worship
claiming claiming authority to change
god's law or to changing god's law
claiming the ability to do that uh is
there an antichrist power or a power
today opposed to christ or trying to put
himself in the place of christ
yes the bible actually says there are
many different
antichrists so there are different
entities and powers but
there is one specific religious power
that claims the
titles that really just belong to god
and
that power is alive and well and
protestants have identified that power
as
the roman pontiff for for many centuries
now
as being in vatican so um yeah thank you
henry we do have a study guide that
actually talks about that and it gets
into the very heart of revelation 13
talks about the antichrist and uh it's
called
who is the antichrist and we'll be happy
to send that to anyone who
calls and asks for that it's the study
guide on the antichrist
the number to call is 800 800-835-6747
and again you can ask for the amazing
facts study guide talking about the
antichrist
and uh pastor carlos i don't know if we
have time to take another caller because
i'm looking at the clock here
friends if we didn't get to you today um
give us another try call us next week
the program of course
you know begins promptly at seven at on
pacific
coast uh call us maybe just a little
before that the phone lines will be open
that way we'll be able to make sure that
we get your call on
the program so again thank you for
calling uh make sure you call and get
those free resources the number there is
800-835-6747
and we would like to encourage you to
take a look at the amazing facts website
if you've never visited the website
before
amazingfacts.org.com it's filled with
great
resources both written resources study
guides
video content different sermons all
about
teaching the bible and helping people to
understand the word of god
and so we hope that you'll take
advantage of that pastor carlos thank
you for
joining us this evening and friends we
look forward to meeting with you again
next week
as we study god's word until then god
bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay california
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country
come together to reveal the hidden
history of the book of revelation
with powerful reenactments and
incredible visual effects
this 95-minute masterpiece brings to
life the book of revelation
like never before revelation is no
longer a mystery
get your copy today visit itunes or
afbookstore.com
journey back through time to the center
of the universe
discover how a perfect angel transformed
into satan
the archvillain the birth of evil
a rebellion in heaven a mutiny
that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet
and the first humans witness the
temptation and evil
discover god's amazing plan to save his
children
this is a story that involves every life
on earth
every life
the cosmic conflict if god is good
if god is all-powerful if god is love
then what went wrong
[Music]
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website
at www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6747
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org
did you enjoy this program make sure to
tell your family and friends
tune in next time for more bible answers
live
honest and accurate answers to your
bible questions
[Music]